on average over 8,000 people die each
year in the US because they can't get an
organ transplant but what if we could
actually rebuild our failing organs that
possibility of creating anything you
want from home could be just around the
corner with a 3d printer what is 3d
printing what is 3d bioprinting and how
many of us are using 3d printers this is
what if and here's what would happen if
every home had a 3d printer could we
become super human and live forever
right now our bodies face the
possibility of breaking down but what if
we could wipe out that risk by creating
medical devices that can help us like
hearing aids pacemakers or new dentures
imagine if we could actually bio-print
our vital organs first off what is 3d
printing 3d printing is a manufacturing
process that takes a digital file known
as a computer-aided design or CAD and
brings that 3d model to life the most
common 3d printing process is known as
fused deposit modeling or FDM it works
the same way as your standard inkjet
printer except instead of ink it uses
thermal plastic material which gets
pushed through a nozzle like a hot glue
gun a spool of filament is loaded into a
printer and gets heated up it keeps
layering 2d cross-sections in thin
horizontal lines that sit atop one
another until you end up with a solid
three-dimensional object so what is 3d
bioprinting it's the creation of living
tissues such as blood vessels bone
heart cells skin cells or cartilage
imagine what 3d bioprinting could do for
organ donations in 2019 in the u.s.
there were more than 100,000 people on
waiting lists for organ transplants the
average wait time for a kidney is
between three and five years scientists
hope that someday soon they'll be able
to bio-print a kidney all they'll
require is a sample of your blood to
create one in six to eight weeks imagine
the lives this would save advances in
this biotechnology would allow us to
eliminate testing on animals instead we
could use three-dimensional living
tissue which would be more accurate when
conducting medical studies dying of old
age could be eliminated when certain
parts of your body start to deteriorate
you could swap them out lungs heart
liver whatever you desire just replace
them every 20 years or sooner if needed
like upgrading to the newest version of
an iPhone what would happen if every
home had a 3d printer how would your
life change you wake up in the morning
log into your computer and type pancakes
minutes later your breakfast is printed
and ready
now what should I wear today a new shirt
it is next shoes perfect then you drive
to work in your 3d printed car 3d
printing would allow us to create
anything we dream of a one-stop Amazon
shop right under your own roof in the US
alone there are approximately 126
million households and in 2018 2 out of
every 1000 homes had a 3d printer it'll
be years before 3d printing is feasible
in the average home but imagine if they
became affordable for the average
consumer retailers could be removed from
the economic equation with consumers
choosing to print virtually anything
they want the 3d printing industry is
rapidly growing despite the fact that
less than 1% of global manufacturers
currently use this technology in 2019
the market grew to over ten point four
billion dollars crossing the double
digit billion threshold for the first
time in its nearly 40-year history the
3d printing market is set to double in
size every three years with an annual
growth forecasted between 18% and 27%
what would the impact be on the
environment
3d printing would create less need for
transportation and distribution
resulting in a smaller carbon footprint
finally a well-deserved break for Mother
Earth well maybe not
3d printing currently relies primarily
on plastics that produce toxic
byproducts and fumes it also requires a
lot of energy some 3d printing processes
call for fifty to a hundred times more
electricity than traditional injection
molding methods to make an object of
equal weight
what would crime look like in the 3d
printing world what's to stop someone
from 3d printing illegal drugs weapons
or bootleg products governments would
have to impose restrictions on a tool
that could provide endless possibilities
but before you get too excited the
reality of every home having a 3d
printer as a common household item is
doubtful the cost of materials is still
expensive and the skill required to make
and assemble finished objects is high
similar to the prediction of everyone
having flying cars we likely have a long
road ahead of us well perhaps but that's
a story for another what if
[Music]